in five four three two one hello welcome
to another episode of the genius brain
podcast for all of our new listeners out
there just to put this is the most
serious podcast that you will ever
listen to we only talk about very
serious topics such as how to survive a
gang fight with just your fists and on
your elbows and maybe a forehead oh that
you wanna for it that's one stronger yo-
forehead or alex is for it a listen to
the previous ever swarms like that was
by far one of the best fights I've ever
seen you do UFC history now if I wasn't
dude it was so good I thought it was the
at first it was that Izzy and Kelvin
Gastelum fight and that [ __ ] right there
might definitely to me beat the best
championship fight I've ever seen
definitely and say first model and what
the [ __ ] you oughta has in her [ __ ]
head
they were both eating shots dude that's
what you mean
take one give three because I felt like
when watching Shang Whaley take the hit
she would take the jab and she's like
[ __ ] it cuz it reaches waste yeah that
way sure she would just eat it slightly
and then just return with that vicious
hook you crack dude her left hook is one
of the best I've ever seen before it's
so fast it's so fast and it's so clean
like it's so perfect the Brian Perry
hook god bond dude yeah this sheet that
[ __ ] was crazy remember watching it I
this is how good that fight was right so
I my grandma was visiting and she was at
my mom so I went to my mom's I got my
grandma my mom my little sister and my
step that all watched it everybody was
so in such as I am yeah everyone said oh
man oh man my mom's like I want the
Asian girl to win she's so cute and she
everybody was so into my little sister
posted it on her Instagram story the
next day this was such a good fight
that's how amazing that fight I ever
watch I mean they're they know about
fighting me because I like to Train and
I'm super into it but they don't ever
watch it
I'm not even going why Shang Whaley just
looks like [ __ ] a Jason Chen in a
[ __ ] bra
long hair yeah I was like is Jason
fighting in that case right now I got
the same we she's built to just [ __ ]
people up dude she's a monster like
she's jacked - she's jacked
when she got hit with that she caught
the kick it was the roundhouse and then
she launched she did that seven times
the whole fight and landed all seven
times you know what the crazy thing was
when Jana switched over to southpaw she
started giving her a little trouble it
was like round two or three yeah yeah
then she adjusted and started [ __ ]
her up and yeah I was like how the [ __ ]
did she adjust to her southpaw mid
fighting and she was like okay I'm gonna
figure this out and still return and
start beating her ass that's how good
she is has a heart of a champion dude I
can't mentality I still can't believe
when people see that fight and they go
clearly you wanna won or clearly no
there was no clear winner that was so I
couldn't even wrap my head around what
was going on do you guys know who islam
makhachev is uh-huh
he's khabib 'he's like training partner
that's not already no cheating ass a
quitter he goes and after this fight
happens and he goes this is not a
woman's sport yeah yeah he was like yeah
he was like oh women should not be
fighting with like one of those like
hands on the forehead emojis I'm pretty
sure that's why what oh yeah yeah we're
gonna fight in the UFC ever again
everybody was he's fighting uh he's
finding out like I heard someone talking
about this and they do kind of have a
solid point which I don't agree with him
obviously right but they were talking
about like okay this guy's from Dagestan
right people need to understand the
culture they're Muslim right they're
Muslim right this is their culture it's
not like he would grew up in the United
States and lived here and he grew up
Muslim he lives in Dagestan they're
straight Muslim this is exists how it is
over there women don't do this type of
stuff so yeah you know that's exactly
how he grew up so yeah and they were
talking about Habib right Habibi they
were like hubby probably thinks is the
same exact thing he's just a little
smarter to not go and tweet it out if
that's my point though it's like yeah I
understand that you are where you're
from you live what you do and that's
your life but you are now on a public
platform and so he's I mean whoever his
PR person is kind of [ __ ] up that's
why Ali of these whatever his name is
I was like sleaze Yabba sleaze he was
like yo delete that tweet dawg yeah yeah
delete it immediately what the [ __ ] are
you think that's the thing right yeah
you can think that way right but yeah
don't be posting it because you're not
only posting it for dagestan people to
see anymore it's for the whole entire
world to see
so now you're they're gonna lose a bunch
of fans and all type of [ __ ] but yeah I
saw the shadow spiders just
problematically or not just fighters I
think a lot of entertainers me including
we forget that the world there's a
public platform now right with Twitter
and social media so I don't really think
about that too much and I realized that
[ __ ] too specifically with the whole
deal on tape while the thing in the the
radio raheem [ __ ] to this day you know
we was doing that [ __ ] what was the
backstory on that again so so this is
what I thought when I first saw it right
and a lot of people disagree with me on
this and I was I was like I gave radio
raheem a benefit because I've been on
the interviewee side right yeah and so a
lot of the times what happens with these
interviewers they want you to sound good
they're not there to trash you right and
I'd even know about radio raheem
previous relationship with Deontay
Wilder what was that they've talked
before they've had conversations they
were friends so what these interviewers
will do if they don't prep you they'll
lob you an easy question so you could
thoroughly explain your stuff right
sound better and have a good exactly so
somebody says to me about the whole
crazy rich Asians and things right so
they come up to me and they go turning
like a red carpet interview and they go
hey soso is crazy rich Asians very
important for Asian people of media
would I come out and be like what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] do you mean like have
you known that there aren't Asian faces
in the media are you in a [ __ ] hole
what if I said that two of them
conversely right cuz when I heard that
question I was like oh radio Raheem is
lobbing him a question but he took that
as like oh why are you acting like new
[ __ ] Uncle Tom like you don't know
what I'm like what is it what did he ask
him he basically asked him about I can't
remember exactly I know yeah it's about
black culture and kind of like what what
do you what he what he's trying to stand
for in terms of what black people are
going through today and he's like what
you what are you not black like a black
man asking me this [ __ ] yeah you know
[ __ ] like that there's like you're one
to right or some shades I yeah that's
you to what he was saying is it's like
it like what Radio Raheem was like dawg
we know each other I know you know I
know this yeah
so why the [ __ ] would you come at me
like this like I'm asking what he was
saying to is it this is an international
platform yeah you're also going get
somebody from the UK American black
history pertains to American people so
not he goes what you don't you don't
have the internet Google that [ __ ] dog
do you know [ __ ] about Europe Deonte I
know you don't know anything about
Europe if I asked him on the spot do you
know [ __ ] about Europe do you know the
[ __ ] that black people go through in
Europe you probably don't know and so
because it's an international platform
he's get lobbing him a question to be
like yo and he botched it anything and
then he made [ __ ] radio Raheem look
like an Uncle Tom which him as an
interview he was like yo I'm lobbying
you a good question so you couldn't look
good yeah so why did you core homies and
we're friends so what the [ __ ] but they
squashed it after wouldn't any started
using that for like merchant [ __ ]
exactly which kind of video is so scary
though it was frightening I think I
remember the video like kind of zooming
in on that he was shocked he's like yo
man like I'm trying to help you out and
also too because there was a narrative
of about Tyson Fury he's also a [ __ ]
right yes when he calls himself the
gypsy king I'm not sure if that's a
derogatory term or not I think it is but
I don't really know still lives in a
caravan bro yes yeah is a gypsy king and
so you know gypsy people are also people
who are looked down upon so he has his
like people struggle versus the black
American struggle so he was trying to
create the narrative of that versus him
saying oh I don't know what black people
go through incite broke clearly as a
black male he understand he knows what
this is so he's like oh you're trying to
get like a sensationalized piece right
now it's like no you dumbass like what
I'm trying to do is lob you a question
as your friend so you could explain
yourself because your angle right now is
that you are speaking for the people
case in point
after he got [ __ ] up in that Tyson
Fury fight he's over here in his room
with a [ __ ] hoodie on or some [ __ ]
don't like my peoples yeah eyes again
have you seen yeah I saw let me look
that [ __ ] up dude that's that was enough
talking about the interview sort of
something like that did you guys see the
whole thing with Tony Ferguson like
there was kind of a little story about
it about how wait
conference yeah so some press
conferences great well yeah so if you
guys haven't watched the the interaction
between khabib in puppey Habib and and
Tony Ferguson that press conference
I may be watched it like two or three
times what's the guy like straight sup
give him yes seems like you know makes
you like you overcame mental health
apparently that guy he's a fight or two
but he also works at he's ex-military
guy too
yeah so he's worked with a lot of like
PTSD and worked through a lot of like
depression things like that so he was
really excited to - so he brings it up
he's like you know you're you're here
you're gonna fight this champion just
really brave yeah bring it's really
break the overcame mental you know help
me shop sense Ally and his response was
[ __ ] you he was a [ __ ] your eyes yeah
and he's like oh I'm not trying to be
he's like [ __ ] your advice he's nice
question I'm not trying to give you
advice I'm trying to give you props but
okay yeah it's like yeah hello dude that
I was seeing seeing people talk about
that and that was like that was the
worst response I should have been like
open about it and be like this is what I
did to get here loud because people are
probably watching feeling the same way
we I also watched an interview after
that press conference I interviewed 20
Ferguson and I found who was I think was
like Brett Okimoto or something like
that and he starts bringing up like you
know he was talking about who's your
team and Tony first his wife yeah and
then he was like oh yeah like you and
your wife have gone through and he was
like careful yeah careful careful and I
was like dude but like Tony Ferguson is
a wild man bro I
well Tony Ferguson lives in his own
world so when he responds like that I'm
like that's about Tony Ferguson yeah
yeah it seems alright but have you seen
there's like all these compilations on
YouTube it's called like two or three
minutes of tony first and trying to
injure himself yeah all these training
oh he does weird [ __ ] but he's also like
it's it's obviously from a coach's
perspective you're like hey don't do any
of that
mmm but it's also amazing how good he is
it's also he's also on like a 13 fight
win streak bro this month he was on a
hoverboard
long-pressing like clean long-press
Anstis lawn upbeat and then back
flipping off of like a BOSU ball I would
go train with him and do this [ __ ]
well I really would do you would have
lasted no none of us would last a day
because we'd all bust our asses I'd last
to this [ __ ] right here dude he's like
really sad nice song is he
first of all let's pause this real quick
what where did the Black Panther [ __ ]
makanda axis become a he was I I am here
yo yo ki yo Keane is here I don't know
what I'm going to do later but I got hit
in the face real hard
Deonte relax per se first of all by the
way I actually love Deontay Wilder
because you got that heater in it's
handy but I thought you took the loss
really poorly will talk about the suit
[Music]
that we'll be back
your king is in great spirits spirit
spirit where did you get this speech
this is dope hey I'm not gonna lie it
this is straight off the dome that's
fire hey you know how to rap go to rap
come here good war has just begun oh my
love hey again I love Deonte the war was
finished though because he lost the
first fight and then he lost again he
lost again in my opinion your way the
way Tyson Fury got dropped like he got
cracked he was out on his feet as he's
going down gets hit with another hook
goes the opposite direction and for him
to get up and be all good up like the
Undertaker is so insane Loki I like I
remember when it first happened I
thought he was kind of faking really I
thought he was because of how fast he
got up and how stable he was so I think
I think that first shot rocked him but I
you know how like sometimes you see
possible a little bit a little bit but
you know how sometimes in fights when
someone gets dropped and they kind of go
flat they get hit again and wakes him up
yeah I think that other that our second
hook that hit him as he was going down
woke him up yeah so I think he fell on
the floor and realized what happened I'm
just speculating it's a veteran suit
because he got up so quick and
immediately started beating the [ __ ] out
of wow there yeah right so I'm like to
me I kind of felt like he did that on
purpose so my question is right and Voxx
ain't when you wouldn't if somebody
scores a knockdown mmm usually it
becomes coz if there has to be a 10-9
scoring system so if someone scores a
knockdown it's ten eight in their favor
yeah if that happens but a guy comes
back that got knocked it out of you and
started beating his ass how do you score
that nine ten or ten nine I would say
for Tyson for Deonte yeah so that's my
thing my personal opinion because a wash
Deonte won two rounds one of the rounds
was a 10-8 cuz he did knock him down
early and it was closer around yeah last
round he knocked him down with beat
tyson beats share them so 1 10 8 1 10 9
yeah
two rounds right even what a 10-8 what
about the other 10 exactly he got [ __ ]
up so I'm like I don't know how that was
a draw I would I think obviously boxing
is little you know but
that's why this one was cool because
Tyson was able just to finish it he was
dude he was like I look so good this
podcast is brought to you by fiber my
friends let's talk about finding
freelance talent for your business or
project finding the right freelancer can
be time-consuming frustrating and
expensive trust me I know in the
business that I'm in that or all three
of those problems are stuff that I've
actually run into so if you guys are
looking where to find item thailand
talent you can find it on Fiverr I've
actually used fiber for multiple things
any kind of song that I drop if I need a
quick album cover I find people who are
graphic designers illustrators to create
my album artwork the communication is
super easy they have guidelines like the
artist will write guidelines about what
he could deliver by what time the
communications is super simple and
payment is really easy as well so I've
been able to use fiber for a lot of the
things that I do there's 24/7 customer
service you could search by service
deadline price reviews and a bunch more
to make it super easy for you paying you
could pay stuff up front so there's no
negotiating needed as well I know first
10 and because that's how I go about
getting my artwork for a lot of the
stuff that I do even on this channel so
take five and check out fiverr.com and
you will receive 10% off your first
order by using my code g/b it's so easy
don't waste any more time and get the
service you deserve by going to five-0
are.com code g/b Fiverr it starts here I
mean the idea while there is such an
interesting box or just because I mean
if you guys seen
Deonte box like he's not the most
technically sound boxer ever in terms of
his footwork especially like how clean
his hits are there's sloppiest fun he
knocked out Ortiz that was probably with
his cleanest punching combinations the
one 200 chop jab Jorge yeah the sweat
that came off me was it that one name is
sweat that was the spirit just came out
he was like what happened that was holy
cuban all ago so holding him out of his
body that was insane that was insane
jothee while the twos like I like him
because he got [ __ ] like heaters in
his hands right he knocks people the
[ __ ] out and also to I think what he
stands for to I think a lot of just like
just black people [ __ ] with him a lot
because he does
he does bring awareness to a lot of like
black plight no you do that stuff and
then you come out in that [ __ ]
ridiculous suit right ass beat you come
out you go now I was 245 pounds suit
that weight my legs down it's like come
on and then also go on another podcast
talking about how you train what a four
pound suit on come on and trust me I'm
very knowledgeable with weights I know
how it feels to lift weights our
elliptical trainer forty pounds on you I
don't care what anybody says
your whole body's extreme as an athlete
as an athlete your whole body is
carrying that it's not gonna affect you
that much what would you say what would
you say about the distribution of weight
literally he was like seven feet taller
when he wore that [ __ ] suit on - I
mean like I said it probably did affect
his legs but here's the thing by the
time they took it off of him right in
the ring the [ __ ] announcements and
[ __ ] themselves take like ten minutes
did you see his face when I took it off
like in my head like in retrospect I was
thinking I was like man he looks like
kinda either either the moment got to
where he realized like I did it this is
deep down he has to understand that like
man the first fight that happened like
yeah I kinda i don't wanna say he got
lucky but it was one of those things
where he's like that could happen to me
again so this I could get out Bob this
is what I think in this fight yeah I
think I think he was scared not scared I
think he was nervous because final round
of the fight he hits Tyson Fury with the
hardest punch right everything he had
left right knocks him down he gets back
up and he beats the [ __ ] out of him
in his head he's like I hate this guy
with everything I do yeah and he because
you matter yeah so I think he was a
little nervous going into it I just
personally I don't think like if I can I
can give you guys 40 pounds until you go
walk around dog and then you get to take
it off and chill for 10 minutes I mean
your legs are gonna be fine I think the
shittiest thing is like you get your ass
beat like that and then afterwards the
guy start seeing karaoke man Tyson Fury
is you know what that fool Tyson Fury
said Tyson Fury says that he jacks off
seven times a day to get him well about
the other thing
that he's uh he was eating [ __ ] he's
Derek Lewis in boxing world bro so
interesting that dude
I like Deonte too for this fight I
wanted Tyson away and I thought Deonte
was gonna win that thought he's gonna
come out I wanted the way the wind just
because America yeah that's it you know
true for the homes like we talked about
in our other podcast right I grew up
with a lot of black people and I hung
around that you know I honestly tend to
go for Hispanic before black people I
honestly do so I was like you know I
want I think Deonte is gonna take this I
think okay he did hit him he got caught
but I think now he knows how this is
gonna go
no one's ever catch him facts and fury
like a political drawing of a white
person for real looks like a cartoon
look he looks like a Tiffany was
watching it with us and she goes she she
looks like the despicable me got robbed
like [ __ ] box of doing we are the
longest [ __ ] are dude like I'm a
black dude drew a racist cartoon of
white person has exactly right now how
big these both with them both of them
are that small dude six seven six nine
yeah insane
oh my six ninety six nine and two
hundred and what seventy pounds I think
that's a fight 262 Dion say putting on
weight kind of jacked him up see he
should have just kept it light like he
always did yeah I don't understand why
these guys are gonna put like Andrew
like Andy worries obviously he wasn't
taking care well anyways was just eating
[ __ ] like menudo [ __ ] like the
hello
he had like vlogs and he would just like
I didn't like it like ten tacos later
that night everything dude he was
killing the food man he should have be
killing the gym but he went after the
[ __ ] Avenue 26 tacos look he don't
like like I still think any Ruiz is a
better boxer than dude I mean he's he's
amazing know why I called the Joshua
fight I was we were at the G I called it
because I work we know I work at a fight
shop and we watch fights all the time
right and I we we used to go watch these
old boxing fights and I used to like
this guy because he was a Hispanic full
chunky I was like oh this is dope he
looks cool me yeah so he's [ __ ]
fighting being the [ __ ] out of people so
knew who he was and I was already
following him on Instagram all the type
of stuff right so when he got the fight
I was like yo he's gonna shock everyone
like he is so [ __ ] fast and people do
not realize it people don't realize how
fast he is in his is his hands are so
clean there's a good box bro like he
knows how to fight to his body type when
he was like pressure because he's young
he's only I think he's 30 or 29
I think he's younger yeah dude he was
Andrei Arlovski one of his main sparring
partners when Andrei Arlovski was in the
[ __ ] army yeah he's one of his
sparring partners he used to spar with
him all the time he was that wild card
he was with Freddie Roach ah I'm like yo
this guy people are sleeping on him and
then he went and beat him I was like I
called it I thought he's gonna win the
second fight but I didn't know when I
heard that he was putting on he put on
weight I was like oh that's fine you
know maybe he's lifting and then he took
off his shirt you're like oh he ain't
leaves for that and when he was in the
ring you know and he had his like little
uh his his guard his getup right he was
so big that you like see it like seeping
over and I was like yo okay and like he
just couldn't move he had no feet he
couldn bro it looked like he didn't run
at all though well you know it is what
it is hey shout out that's how that's
how you know that that [ __ ] sticks with
you cuz he did he didn't look tired
yeah he just wasn't fast enough to move
like it looked like he was uh his feet
were like behind a vault on he's [ __ ]
short too isn't he yeah and he's like
exactly 6 foot right anthing Joshua
played the perfect game just yeah I'm on
the outside stay on the outside and he
couldn't get in on him could you imagine
if Andy Ruiz dropped like 70 pounds man
he would be killing people do with his
speed if he's that fast when he's that
out of shape imagine what he could do if
he took his no training seriously it was
serious yeah yeah I know it's great like
if they were to do a third one I think
if Annie Ruiz gets a [ __ ] together
Araki that's why they're not gonna do it
they're not gonna do it if Anthony
Joshua fights Tyson Fury I think Tyson
career well Anthony dodge would even
even before that the first fight that he
lost when he got cracked with Joshua I
was surprised like how bad he was hurt I
was a tiny hurt so finally he got her
in the in sparring yeah he got a
supposedly got knocked out a week be in
the week of a week of that's a they said
they said like he had an anxiety attack
before the fight like in my locker room
like he like broke down because he was
so worried about getting hit and sure
enough and half got hit and then he got
wobbled super I was like like you're
like Bambi legs dude yeah I was like how
did he get run then Harper did he kind
of get hit in the back of the head no it
was right on the ear right be right back
right yes see those are the shots man
that like just messes with people really
bad can I think
Deonte got hit kind of towards the back
of the head cuz he turned his head so
yeah like when you get hit there it he
did it look the same after that first
knockdown and then obviously he was his
ear was bleeding so and during the time
during the fight everybody was like oh
[ __ ] D like pop up you're drunk because
that's her equilibrium like that you're
you're [ __ ] after that cuz after that
that first knockdown he was literally on
stilts the all time discombobulated and
then and then I don't think he was ready
for Tyson Fury the freshman going back
to the suit right I mean like I said it
could happen like [ __ ] we were
training right and I was doing some
stupid [ __ ] bouncing and my quads got
super also doing the worm this is very
true remember that right idle [ __ ] were
you doing the worm and he does he did
fours backward backwards hey I learned
quick good I learned how to do it
backwards first I couldn't do it for why
I don't know I just I knew how to do a
backwards risk over but so will it be
the most fascinating man I'll do it so
when I did I was doing this stupid [ __ ]
my quads remember they got super pumped
but three minutes passed and if I'm fine
so I just don't buy the whole suit [ __ ]
I'm like no yeah I don't think anybody
that's the thing - it's like I like
Deontay Wilder but it's like when you
take a loss just take the [ __ ] loss
me I'll take this like even if it that
was the case don't say that you should
know he goes it was because the 45 pound
suit and then you go into your into a
room and you start talking about your
king is here it's like wrong you're not
doing a good job in it look [ __ ]
insane what happened to you go does
gotta yeah I think yeah what you said
you just have to take accountability for
that right
just like when we had that little muy
Thai fight like I just
don't have all these things like oh I
think I did this better I did this
better I want I want it was like you you
just need more hands in your face that's
all man no you just need more hands in
your face let's do the fight bro
immediately me a song shout outs by the
way - [ __ ] it [ __ ] it jay Park you got
slapped
jay Park got slap her you can hear it in
that video yeah I didn't yeah I didn't
see the video you couldn't see anything
you know I see it but you hear it that's
loud
oh really you heard it heard it yeah you
hear it and you know Brian no take as a
boxer - that bull just came up with the
heater - just slap the [ __ ] out like I
told y'all is gonna slap you like a
[ __ ] yeah so apparently what that story
I don't know how true this is because
I'm I don't think there's a confirmation
on it but jay Park apparently got
slapped up by Brian Ortega because jay
Park funny enough like first of all I
had a video with him he's a really
really cool dude i like jay Park a lot
talented [ __ ] right cute little
boy so he how big is he like he's tiny
he's small who would you compare site
lies and shayzon's more no no he's not
that sharp and he's like five like my
guy is he like my guy Daniel my client
down no he's beefier than him for sure
cuz so cuz jay Park is also a b-boy so
you know he got some muscles to me just
like that big shoulder shrug that is war
sign me up I'll teach ya want people to
respect me I'm good so yeah so jay Park
apparently he got upset at O'Brien
Ortega got upset at him and I guess they
squash something behind the scenes where
he was like a man like I didn't like the
way that you translated something or it
was something along that line yeah those
lines and he was like who got it but I
guess like afterwards from what I read
was that Jay Park mistranslated what
Korean Zombie said like again right
exactly so what was the translation I
think that kinda zombie said I could
look it up but it was basically it was
like he was ducking yeah yeah I remember
that was I think that's what he
embellished now it's out and that was it
happened twice he said that some [ __ ]
like that before then I agree and zombie
was like yo that's not what I said right
and they squash like you said exactly
and he
reset it again on on a hurry Oh wanna
show saying that oh he's dodging
rescheduling versus ducking is two
different things yeah exactly
so that's one and he warned him about
that [ __ ] he said if you knew that must
slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you like
don't do that stuff right and so you
know if that's if that's the case then
Jay Park I love you to death man but you
you're talking about a dude that grew up
in East LA he's footage [ __ ]
and he's a [ __ ] fighter and you
[ __ ] with his name if he says he's
gonna slap you he's gonna slap the [ __ ]
out you and the funniest thing about
this whole altercation let me just read
what Korean Zombie wrote hold on y'all
continued to other thing about Brian
Ortega's like dude why did you [ __ ]
slap that people yeah who do you slap
like a translator or some other person
and I think he just slapped a woman with
the pregnant like a pregnant woman I'm
Canada oh my god the fact that he
slapped like you know Jamie it's like
you don't have to do that bro so here's
your game - his face is long so
supposedly it was he did it after Korean
zombie laughs right that's what it was
it's like all right so number one you
shouldn't hit him no matter
yeah if even if you just checked the
[ __ ] he's gonna get scared of
[ __ ] right go up so be like yo he's like
what I say what I say [ __ ] you're gonna
talk to shell my slap you and like just
fake to do it have a flinching like
there you go [ __ ] [ __ ] will [ __ ]
happen again I swear if you keep talking
this [ __ ] I'm gonna tell what [ __ ]
Alice grew up I'm over here sweating my
ass off what the other thing though too
is like I don't know part of me when I
when I hear someone like like jay Park
says something like that and Bryan
Ortega he does not need any hey shadow
brown Ortega - yeah like not Latino
brother right there that fool does not
need to talk about his resume like he is
one of the biggest fighters in the UFC
especially the featherweight division
and we all know he's tough as [ __ ] and
he's a badass certified badass so I
don't know why he's even wasting his
time with a guy like Jay Park but it
does sell let's listen we could talk
about Brian's [ __ ] right now so this is
what Brian T city wrote my man's with
the hands is this is this after the
incident yeah so Jay parts I'm Korean
zombie to a management
under aomg entertainment which is Jay
Park [ __ ] of which Park is the CEO and
soon after the trash-talking began when
I finally made it to Korea for the press
conference
Korean Zombie approached me with his
translator a real one not jay Park AHA
and said I want to apologize for the
trash-talking it was my management that
wants to do it to promote the fight I
accepted his apology shook his hand and
we had a great press conference soon
after I tore my knee and the fight got
cancelled four weeks ago Korean Zombie
and JP went on Ariel's show and said I
dodged the fight dodging an injury are
two separate things and since I already
knew Jay Park was the one writing the
script that's when I welcomed him to the
fight game and and warned him to watch
his mouth but he welcomed him to the
fight game this is jay jay park's
response I'm a singer bro I weigh 143
pounds I'm like 40 pounds lighter than
you he's the number two UFC fighter in
the world it doesn't make you look tough
it was just weird this podcast is
brought to you by purple my friends
sleeping is so important to me I need to
sleep well in order for me to survive
because we all know a big part of
functioning like 100% human being homie
is sleeping well and I do that on my
purple mattress the best mattress I've
ever put my body on it's amazing I'm
talking about the science behind it is
developed by rocket scientist so if you
haven't blessed your beautiful body on
this what are you doing you're probably
not sleeping that well the purple
mattress my friends have a hundred night
risk free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your mattress
for a full refund backed by a 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns
isn't that amazing get the best night's
sleep of your life and invest into a
purple mattress baby yes you're going to
love purple and right now my listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts are
offering site-wide just tix brain to
eight four - eight eight eight the only
way to get this Reap illo is a text
brain to a four - eight eight eight
that's be are a I n two eight four eight
eight eight message and data rates may
apply but also to you know what's kind
of weird you're talking [ __ ] to a
fighter and you expect to not get
slapped and here's the thing right so
like Brian Ortega's from where he's from
and I'm from where I'm from the kana sim
right yeah the whole thing is like if
someone's talking [ __ ] and like you get
Brian Ortega goes to confront him right
and it's still the same [ __ ] like he
could be like yeah [ __ ] like make them
flinch right like all right you don't
you don't like that [ __ ] right I'm like
that's just for real next time you keep
talking that mouth right yeah I better
way to do it but also when you're in
that situation you want to slap the [ __ ]
it's almost like testing is gangster
right like oh you keep I already told
you not to talk [ __ ] and you're
continuing to talk [ __ ] and then you're
in front of that person and you're just
like you know what [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ]
slap you real quick to teach you a
lesson so I kind of understand it as
well too but at the same time for sure
yeah at the same time cuz like I'm not
even a professional fight or anything
but I don't know I don't even want to go
fight anybody ya know it's like so [ __ ]
like and going back to what pretty much
what Korean zombie like translated yeah
it's it's a dude like jay Park like he's
he's very so smart like he's harmless
I'm sure he's a really nice dude but at
the same time it's like you're picking
your battles hey also it's supposed to
be like three-strikes-you're-out
be hey so you only gave him two strikes
the [ __ ] funniest thing about this
isn't this is like what I was talking
about cuz me and Bart were cracking up
about this because this is Korean
zombies post that he wrote to Brian
Ortega at that he goes last night you
said ten meters of shout-out cuz he's in
Korea meters away from me my life for
two hours nothing happened so I thought
everything was fine and angry John wrote
on Instagram but you [ __ ] attack jay
Park while I went to the bathroom to
take a poop together I had a hot dog and
it hurt
jay Park is not a professional fighter
but a musician you slapped the civilian
who merely helped translate even worse
you were sitting there waiting until I
would be absent in attack jay Park it
was not a fight like real men do what
you have done is same as as a grown up
beating up a child
you should have attacked me if so I
would have not been asset you are such a
counter for slapping a musician not a
fighter if you [ __ ] plan this to
fight me and to use my name because
people don't remember your name anymore
then I congratulate your work I will
fight you and I will knock you and your
[ __ ] face we bloody well now your
[ __ ] face stays in my mind and I will
[ __ ] you up in that cage I hope you
won't run away from me again
the funny thing is he's trying to defend
jay Park he's making Oliver biggest
[ __ ] ever punching him is like punching
a child away from his parents basically
what he said basically this wasn't he
was going he was like basically jay Park
is a bigger [ __ ] punch a bigger [ __ ]
my friend is like a little girl okay you
gotta stop the skin and you're gonna hit
a little girl with a sock the other day
jay park was a crying in his room
i said mike he's like yeah right that
she's like reading a tie he's like yeah
jay Park saw a man yo chill bro yeah
yeah you don't have to put that part in
there cuz I alright I said no I have to
say what does it make it all a kid
though you know jay Park use a lot of
lotion on his skin care routine is
impeccable yeah but but it's funny
because you know like i said i like jay
Park I like his music I like him as a
person I like everything about him he's
actually a really real ass dude you know
what the other honestly never heard
anything but he's [ __ ] music Speyer
but the other thing about like what
Brian he's probably was very frustrated
and I told yes I'm saying yeah but the
other thing though too is who would you
rather slap would you rather slap a guy
like Korean zombie or jay Park because
Korean Zombie just seems like a really
[ __ ] nice guy yeah and also Korean
Zombie wasn't the one talking [ __ ] so
it's like he doesn't want to slap ya
yeah and also Brian was by himself
yeah from the video he gets think about
himself so it's like shootin fish in a
barrel
I so I also get why he waited for that
personally right he had no beef with
that person he wanted to handle his beef
with the one person that was talking to
[ __ ] I think I think that's what it
mostly is like like in his mind he's
like you know what I have a problem with
this dude not this green zombie I'm
gonna talk to him I wonder if he says I
need to him before he just slapped the
shove them that's what I'm wondering I'm
wondering and I'm also wondering like
if Jay parks had some shoes right that's
what I think too because it's very
random for someone like a guy like you
you look at T City he looks like a
really chill nice guy he is like Keith
the way I found out he slapped the [ __ ]
of jay Park I was like in my head
immediately I thought I was like oh he
must have been talking [ __ ] why jay Park
must have said something to him and then
Bryan was like what the [ __ ] and slap
the show that's the thing too because
like his his account for the story is
that and I'm gonna give Jay Park the
benefit of the doubt Yeah right but
there's also things that can be
communicated non-verbally they can slap
in the [ __ ] face yeah
case in point I have also been slapped
in the face before by my parents because
I communicate his [ __ ] verbally it's not
verbally you just look at of a certain
exactly so it's like smile while they're
serious exactly so maybe that maybe
Brian I was like yo man I heard you
talking that [ __ ] I told you not to do
it and he just smiles there he goes
Tom to slap so there's a lot of things
that could have happened because like
Jay parks accounting goes I just stood
there and he slapped me out of nowhere
hundred times out of a hundred times
that never ever ever ever had unless the
dude is on crack or he's like some kind
of crazy person yeah every time somebody
I've seen gets sock or slap growing up
is because they had some kind of weird
nonverbal [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] on the side
they said some [ __ ] at the side of the
mouth and they got slapped and you know
you can't really act like tough with
these kinds of guys or yeah or unless
Brian told them like when they had their
conversation if you say some [ __ ] like
that again
it's on site and that's what happened
yeah so out of [ __ ] yeah you just
he could have always just walked up to
me AJ waited for him to turn around but
I slapped the [ __ ] out of told you
because it I told you I was gonna slap
you like a [ __ ] yeah yeah I bet
something happened where he kind of like
gave him a glance maybe was unattended
maybe he was taking the wrong way but I
feel like something definitely because
jay Park versus CM Punk my [ __ ] must
because like if Jay parks McCreery
here's the problem with the response of
saying that yo I'm just I'm a musician
bro like fighting me doesn't make you
tough it doesn't mean that you could say
whatever the [ __ ] it's like some white
people [ __ ] like not hitting on my
people I'm saying like the the type of
white people that I grew up around with
it's the mentality that they had like
for example like what somebody would
come up they would do some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] to you and they go why are you
getting hostile it's like you did the
[ __ ] up thing that's why you got
slapped yeah because that response right
there it doesn't really make sense to me
it's like yeah you said something and it
sounds like it because that's never been
yeah bro I'm a musician
I'm only 140 pounds doesn't matter I was
cool so that means you get to talk all
the [ __ ] you [ __ ] want yeah yeah it's
your still guess you don't get a pass
but if anything else if you know that
you're just a musician you should've
stayed in your lane and not translate
like that like once again like who knows
if that really happened I'm only
speculating about like if that was the
situation then that would make so so far
yeah like I would never like for example
like when savant was on this podcast
right he was someone was saying like he
hated Josh Koscheck right like it and I
didn't like him very much too but if
Josh Kosh that came up to me goes yo the
next time you say that [ __ ] i'ma [ __ ]
you up I'm like you damn straight I can
go say [ __ ] yeah alright Sarge my mouth
shut okey I like - Josh Koscheck you
like Josh goes to injuries no Paul de
Leeuw fight all that type of [ __ ] all
those crazy [ __ ] I didn't like but like
when he was on Ultimate Fighter [ __ ] I
was a fan of it was - I mean I kind of
started to like him but at the same time
I was like maybe he's got a shot against
GSP yeah I did and I was like yo this
guy's kind of good I didn't like him
because he had ground game but he
wouldn't do anything yeah I wonder what
he's doing now he's heat so he fought in
Bellator got knocked out how do you get
knocked out by um I forgot Bailey but uh
back no but yeah guys Paul de Leeuw
scariest [ __ ] we've got that grenade the
Grenada looks meanest [ __ ] like it looks
like he's got like the scary British
accent you think that full is Josh
Koscheck is still fighting no he's read
an article where Josh Koscheck was
talking about how he feels sometimes in
the gym and then how he feels in the
cage are two different things
he says when he's in the gym and he's
training and he's cracking people he's
giving people good work he doesn't have
that heart or grit to take it back into
the cage there's something weird he has
that disconnection fighters have when
they go in the cage and they're like the
gym king but you're going to hear that a
lot - yeah so that's what Josh Koscheck
was talking about because I researched
why
he's been yeah it was like a few months
ago but I think he's doing some like
racecar style type of [ __ ]
Ryan Ortega was actually just with him
he put on his story so I went in checked
it cuz I was like I haven't seen Josh
Koscheck
in a minute and yeah he's like building
like those those like dude like the cars
I go in the sand and she point like if I
set that stuff on this podcast and then
Josh Koscheck slapped me I'd be like I
get it yeah I wouldn't be like now was
that desert I wouldn't be like I don't
know why he slapped me I know why it's
because I said I didn't like him on the
podcast you usually when you hear people
say like oh I don't know why this
happened it's like they know why you
know why did you just not saying it yeah
you know exactly why you got slapped up
because it is kind of weird where
someone just gets slapped in the face
yeah out of all the years I've lived in
my life I've never been so unnerving
really slap but like if I were to get
punched in the face by a random person
that I was maybe had contact with yeah
if I just got punched
what I don't know why it's it's one of
the most [ __ ] weirdest thing that's I
don't say weird but like the most angry
I've ever been on campus of school was
when somebody when I was a so we had to
get lockers back in the day and high
school right and when we would get these
lockers you would get a raffle and you
get a ticket and then you have to wait
in line and then get then get the locker
so at you have to do that after school
and it's during like the hottest time
which is towards like the end before I
hit summer so it's like Sacramento gets
like a hundred degrees so we're all
waiting in line and shoutouts to Sarah
my Mormon homie she was like the only
Mormon girl that I knew in high school
besides his dude Sam but Sarah was a
really sweet girl so when I first moved
to this school called
Isabel Jackson's elementary school this
is after I stabbed a kid when I was in
third grade moved over that's not a good
thing man so I'm that is not a good
thing that was a very terrible team and
that's so cool you stabbed that kid yeah
through the cheek like he go relate to
me and we moved on but Sarah was one of
my first friends when I moved to Isabel
Jackson elementary school and she was a
really sweet friend to me and she's
always been such there's a really really
sweet girl so she needed a lock a
partner low and behold she found this
piece of [ __ ] oh so we decided to be
large
smells like kimchi all that and I'm like
wait I think she chose me to be a locker
part because she knows your boy don't
study so it's not like I'm using that
for anything so she basically had an
empty Locker so we would share lockers
of [ __ ] but it was super hot that day
and I remember what this dude looks like
it was as tall as Mexican dude tall and
I was so he was like 6 - maybe it's kind
of skinny dude with his hair slicked
back Oh sick with a lot the one in the
back yes fancy but he wasn't a thug but
he was like trying to front like yeah
there was some very precarious people so
you could smell thug on somebody and he
wasn't a thug he was just rying to
pretend like he was something that he
wasn't
so specifically as an aria we had a lot
of norteño so like you know who the
[ __ ] thugs were you know what and
they weren't in school they were trying
to get in a [ __ ] locker
yeah so you know I was standing in line
and he goes like you see he was like you
about to get a locker I'm like yeah so
he takes my paper and he Chuck's it and
he puts his paper and right right to the
office lady before I come in
I'm like trying to Punk me because I'm
mind you I remember when I was wearing
that day cuz I was so angry I was
wearing this leather baby blue and white
Jordan bucket matches slides with the
white Air Force One oh I did the bucket
had like a little white square with a
load with the extra long white tee it
was a chance to share my bed oh sure I
worked at my parents my mom worked at a
[ __ ] flea market so hey nowadays that
[ __ ] when I went hard cos champs blew
the [ __ ] up again cheap back in the day
so you just get that [ __ ] in packs and
then I wore these baby blue and white
Jordan a basketball shorts over at war
so I was trying to feel looking extra
fly that day you know I'm saying so the
guys like took my [ __ ] crumpled up and
threw it on the floor or whatever and I
move on and I like looked at him I got
[ __ ] mad I grabbed his [ __ ] I was
like this [ __ ] paper and I looked at his
friend and it was his homie I was like
that should homie that should lock a
partner I grab this [ __ ] I [ __ ] tore
that [ __ ] up right through it in the
face and then I remember the only thing
I kept saying over and over it was like
do something or put your hands on me and
see what happens that's all I said
and then you know in high school when
[ __ ] people fight circle perfect circle
around me you know I was such a goofy
nice kid
nobody would ever expect me to just
start throwing now but I open a very bad
neighborhood so when people Punk me
I just knew that I couldn't let somebody
just pump me like that cuz it'll be like
that for the rest of the school year
yeah
so either I go down swinging and then I
will be the most difficult person you're
gonna try to bully yeah oh oh oh I'm
just gonna get pumped for the rest of
the year so I was pissed and I was like
put your [ __ ] hands on me and see
what I just kept saying over and over
and over and then you know like [ __ ]
all the homies are [ __ ] they're like
y'all Davis almost like the class clown
yeah he's not stab this kid like you did
where's a pencil really just nice dude
and then it got that point and I was
gonna swing on this guy and then Sarah
just grabs my hand very sloppily she
goes David please don't and I just
[ __ ] felt terrible because she was
like scared because she's never seen a
[ __ ] she's never seen a before and so
she kind of the slightly grabbed me and
I was I remember this because she she
she hit me up on Facebook not too long
ago she was telling me about the stores
like that's right this but she grabbed
me and that dude just like looked at me
goes man [ __ ] this and he grabs his [ __ ]
and he leaves but I was gonna [ __ ] that
fool up I was so [ __ ] angry I've
never seen somebody just disregard me as
a human being and just throw my [ __ ]
away
that's funny like you remember I feel
like the big times like cuz I was
probably like a big moment in your life
right you're like I'm not gonna take
this [ __ ] right so my very first fist
fight it's funny as you say that because
I remember exactly what I was [ __ ]
wearing yeah a right my grandma had
bought me DC Shoes with Travis Barker
little like stereos you know member
they're all over him right jean shorts
that went past my knees sure are I don't
know why and a [ __ ] collared shirt
that was brown with like tan stripes
across it right yeah you're a fly oh my
god hey whit [ __ ] broken eyes glasses
that were like this broke you try to
bend them back yourself no and so uh
yeah so I used to play we used to play a
slap tag game right huh I used to get to
school hella early cuz when my mom
married my stepdad he had two daughters
we went to school in different districts
so he used to drop us off hella early
they would go and then he had to drop
him off over there so we used to be
there hella early so like we used to
play slapping slap box slap tag whatever
like that and like we the rule was until
the first bell once the bell rings
games done
right so one day we're up at our pod
that's what they call them pods bill had
already rang his my friend's brother was
there with us right before he dips out
he slashed me right he's like you're it
and then runs off and then so like I
even told my friend his name was Adam I
was like hey like that's not the rules
right I get it I get a free slap on him
yeah next time I see him so the next day
we're out there in the front of the
school we're in front of the school
they're chilling like on this big-ass
brick wall him and like a group of
[ __ ] 25 people my friend Adams
they're on my I'll tell your brother I
get a free slap on him because he
slapped me before like after the bell
yeah he's all right cool so he runs it's
just me my friend my friend Jamal my
friend Tony my brother Michael all of a
sudden every single person from that
wall jumps off the wall and starts
walking over towards us and I'm like the
[ __ ] did this hey these people yeah he
comes over and immediately a four heard
you want to [ __ ] fight I was like
it's not what I said I said I owe you a
slap because you slapped me with our
children slimy right now then so you hit
him with the T City no so I was like I
was like [ __ ] okay I guess like then
let's fight am i all right so we're
about to front in front of the school
someone's like nah go take it to the
basketball courts right so we're walking
right and this is one of those things
right it's like I'm not gonna get punked
right when I'm going there so we're
walking to it his homies are all talking
[ __ ] to me they start pushing me into
the wall as we're walking we're walking
because I have three people they got
like 25 and my brother comes up to me -
and he's like Alex I like aunt helped
you out yeah there's like 25 of these
people there I'm like don't worry about
it it's all good right so we walked to
the basketball court remember it night
like perfect right I have a gray sweater
on over that over that collar shirt I
start taking it off as I'm inside my
sweater so our three punches on the top
of my head right hate that [ __ ] Arizona
cans you ain't heard about the Arizona
can't hit the wrong spot homie take it
off this is funny because now this is a
reminding me because we had a
conversation about something else that's
yeah are similar to this take off my
sweater right so we're ready I don't
know how to [ __ ] fight okay all I do
know is is that we had
dumbbell in my dad's house I used to
always put weight on it and throw
punches yeah with the dumbbell whatever
way we had [ __ ] knows why but all
right yeah hey Mike oh yeah look at
maniac we're going I don't know what to
do right he comes we get into like a
close quarters and were kind of like
almost clinched and I push him as he
lands he throws a punch I remember
stepping back hey won't you step back
stepping back closing my eyes and just
throwing punch thrown a punch I didn't
feel it like I was telling you the other
time didn't feel it all I heard was as I
opened my eyes this fool was falling
doing a Superman boom
landing on his back and he kind of like
got up off slow and understanding like
oh [ __ ] what happened and he got up and
like tackled me kind of into the fence
and I just remember feeling his body you
might have noticed he probably rifle he
felt so weak yeah like he was holding me
on the fence but I was just I haven't
but I was at moving in oh yeah I know I
know yeah he was like man I'm done and
then all of his friends screaming and
jumping and all [ __ ] and then all of a
sudden they're all coming up to me
giving me high-fives and all the time so
much so that was like the story at the
school know he had one friend that
wanted to jump me or beat me beat my ass
after school he didn't know how to older
brother that was a [ __ ] junior in
high school that was part of a group I
texted my brother they all showed up
after the school oh [ __ ] let them over
Ginola was back sixth grade so I was I
was always a year older so like if
someone if kids were like 12 I was like
my man got bad over here just [ __ ]
[ __ ] with dumbbells at hope another
goddamn reason no way got help
after that fight I did I asked my dad I
was like dad I want a punching bag right
I mean I don't I'm sure I asked my
parents to like Simon for boxing but but
we didn't have money for them paying for
me to go to gym but he did buy me a
punching bag so I used to punch that
[ __ ] like all everyday for like 20
minutes don't you punch a punch punch it
but yeah we did have a dumbbell and
that's one of the ones that have those
little screws on the side [ __ ]
weights on there tied up punches throw
punches throw punches rocked him dude
yeah so yeah and we were talking about
this so and I asked you because I had
another fight we had the Fight Club and
when I was in high school and I was
telling this kid called me out that
didn't like it was like the first time I
was drinking everybody that was drunk
before you finish the story I feel like
every kid like every male in high school
has a story about how at some point in
time them and their friends were like yo
yeah it would be a thing you know so I
think everybody had a version of it but
it depends on how who you were hanging
out and how extreme it was cuz part also
had a [ __ ] Fight Club and his [ __ ]
was extreme they was just you know just
probably extremism I was just mine was
just light [ __ ] I mean the real fighters
too cuz it was a kid named Preston
Preston had [ __ ] hands dude like
president was a boxer dude and there was
another dude named Reggie that was the
same height as Preston same build and
they were both in football and so they
had them watch each other right
presses like six five they're alive too
long both of them long as [ __ ] but I
think if Reggie stuck with it he could
have been like a Golden Gloves champ so
right I remember when Reggie said like
he's like hey bro like I was trying to
knock this fool this [ __ ] dragon
couldn't touch it man because like
Preston would slip we even roll on all
this [ __ ] so so it's true right so like
Bart had an extreme one dawg I'm telling
you it was like the the people that
started it we started doing it it was
like me my homie Derrick who still
fights to this day our old friend Tyler
like we started at our school and it
kind of like when you think about it
nowadays we we had that [ __ ] going right
we'd go to that table that I told you
guys about that
one time we'd be like yeah who wants to
fight we'd get people's names and then
try to figure out who has classes with
people and set up these [ __ ] fights
and we had like a [ __ ] fight card
yeah for afterward that's what happened
with us too and we knew like oh you got
to be like two miles away from school
and then you're not schools [ __ ] you
know you're not they're not worrying
about you no more they don't their rules
so just have [ __ ] fights like that but
I'm gonna tell you I was telling him
story one of the fight clubs I fought
this kid I didn't like him he called me
out because it was my first day drinking
Loki was taste like [ __ ] so I didn't
drink so I wasn't drunk they thought I
was drunk so I think that's why I called
me out and so he played soccer so I
remember telling my friend Derek I'm
like yo I'm like nervous cuz this fool
is gonna kick me in the shit's gonna
hurt right so we go we put on MMA gloves
we both go and throw like an inside kick
and we get locked up and as I'm coming
back down I throw an overhand right and
I don't even feel it land but like after
I throw it I'm like off the centerline
you know head off the centerline never
do you want to get hit with something
like that but yeah I got off the
centerline hit some as I see him he's
like churning around like this holding
his face so I run after him grab the
back of his shirt hit him with an
uppercut once I see most people when
they see them turn around
oh [ __ ] is over it was like I'm gonna
make him bang another one hit him in the
head with a chair
[Laughter]
I hit him with two and then Derek comes
and stops me but it was all he was like
bleeding right and all [ __ ] up that's
my question it's like are like are the
good punches when you land or those want
you don't feel them or like well a lot
of people when they oh they knock people
out there like oh I didn't even feel it
like it it just like just like I didn't
even know connected you know but it's
weird though cause like I was telling
we're just talking about the story where
I remember we were doing like we were
boxing inside my friend's garage and I
mind you when I say boxing it is the
ugliest thing I've ever seen you guys
are fighting night thumbs up pinkies out
yeah we're just like versus we're
scrapping like a bunch of just nerds
like we're a bunch of dweebs we don't
[ __ ] watch yeah and so we're in the
garage and we're just thrown so there's
this one kid he was like this maaan kid
and he wanted to box me the biggest guy
mind you I'm [ __ ] fat right but at
this time I was taking weight training
and this is so long story short our on
him [ __ ] so long story short when I was
in high school my freshman year of high
school I couldn't do a single [ __ ]
pushup so I'm so I couldn't do a single
[ __ ] push-up and I got mad at
Barataria [ __ ] let me tell you some
flexibility [ __ ] all day touching my
toes oh [ __ ] I wouldn't be that flexible
cuz I wasn't pick one though my whole
life yeah and so right exactly so when
it came to the push-up thing my teacher
Miss Jackson [ __ ] that [ __ ] she
didn't Barry she I'm sorry she legit
didn't think that I couldn't do a
push-up and I told her I can't do a
push-up she goes David so you could do a
push-up I was like I can't do a put I
know cuz she thought I was just trying
to get up doing a testing and I'm like
yo and whenever I ever got a so kind of
any testing in PE like I would just do
it yeah I mean I want to show up to
school most of time but when I was there
I did my [ __ ] and she was like you're
lying to me I need you to do a put
push-up and so my boy David you
and stress I know I gotta feel like
makes me mad
he still mentioned this story because it
still makes him die laughing because in
front of the whole [ __ ] school she
was like do a push-up yelling at me and
I'm trying that I go remembered that
[ __ ] [ __ ] I hated her ever since I was
a [ __ ] this [ __ ] so next year or the
next semester I on fire in the Fight
Club so next year I [ __ ] her who can't
do push-ups now [ __ ] knocking her up
dude that I found her [ __ ]
two-year-old kid write my name out your
mouth that's right and found her husband
cut his brace so what happened was I
doubt and I decided to take a weight
training with coach Eslinger he was our
defensive football coach that's a dope
name exactly
coach Esslinger so I remember the first
day I was there he had like a southern
ass accent and I I could barely bench 65
pounds so he puts that weight on and you
know when you start doing it starts
running all over the place that's cuz
your stabilizers aren't strong enough
basically what you need to do is warm up
your CNS good all right thanks
powerlifting you know and so I would do
this [ __ ] and I remember I couldn't even
lift 65 pounds there was kids who were
half my weight pushing up way more
weight than me so I used to get pissed
and so I just kept working on just doing
bench and squats all the [ __ ] time so
by the end of the semester I maxed out
my bench at 175 so good I went david
pusses - something wrong I don't like
people tell me I can't do something so I
used to get so can't make a million
dollars yes right now what you say don't
make me breath okay that big-ass doors
like this
[Laughter]
so I remember I maxed out my bench at
175 and then after that like I think my
box squat at the time was above 400
pounds because my legs were always
trying well box load you get the
assistance push it up and then I
remember coach Eslinger he was like dave
is so into a football right and I just
kept dodging him but I tried joining
football my parents won't let me join
football because it was too dangerous
but instead I play basketball tear my
ACL oh then I fractured my ankle and I'm
like football probably still a little
bit more dangerous I know Bob I wanted
to play football chops
[ __ ] bad cuz I just wanted to crack
people I feel your pain on that too I
mean you probably would have been really
good at that eyes you have some hate in
your heart I do have a lot of hate in my
heart just because I used to get bullied
all the time and that's why I said you
can bully me but I'll be the most
difficult person that you're gonna bully
ever and your life was a little bit just
until I was like in middle school that's
when I started standing up for myself
and [ __ ] people I've always grown up
hating like the bully [ __ ] like I never
liked it I remember the first time I
tried there was a kid named Hayden I
remember it and it was like I was out
bullied by a kid named no no attempted
and I think I think this is what helped
me like my whole life right because this
kid was the bully at the school it was
Eagle Ridge elementary school right
he was the bully at the school and I
still remember the day that I [ __ ]
when he it came around to me or you try
to bully me right so you know like at
the playgrounds right you can go to the
monkey bars either from the sand you can
climb up the ladder go in the sand or
you can go on the big entrance of the
playground and go to the monkey bars so
I was standing right there about to go
and he comes up behind me and he's like
hey hurry up and go I said I'm gonna go
when I'm ready
right this fool pushes me and I jump in
a laying in the sand right good luck you
know so I got up I grew up with two
older brothers right beating the [ __ ] of
me all the time right yeah so I go up
there that definitely helps he's sitting
right he's standing right there what do
I do 300 I kick him in his back and he
flies into the sand and lands on his
stomach and starts flying her
and so he tried that was the first time
you tried like a couple weeks later he
tried to blow me again we were playing
tetherball which that she used to be so
fun or that [ __ ] yeah
so we were playing it and I was beating
him and he stopped and he grabbed the
rope what you're not supposed to do
right at humor oh that's a DQ and he
stopped and I tried to grab her from and
he kicked me in my shin so I kicked him
he kicked me again and I just I didn't
go for one for one no more I just
started [ __ ] kicking the [ __ ] out of
his legs right you were one of those
[ __ ] kids no for sure
no because I knew he was the bully I
knew he was the bully you bullied some
kid I don't think at the time like I
knew like oh I need to do this cuz he's
a bully and retro I just think like you
know I had two older brothers this is
all him Punk other kids yeah but like I
knew I wasn't gonna let this kid just
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] to me
but I think because I knew that like I
have like a soft spot
soft spot in my heart right so I even
when I see homeless people some of them
I get like sad a little bit right I see
them and on my uh but then I think like
[ __ ] man like they had a family like
that's how I am so I guess with bullying
[ __ ] we never [ __ ] played with that
me and all my friends like if people
were gonna fight we we we were one of
those people like one on one no one
jumps in our group we never jumped in
jumped anybody like that and like we had
a homie named tree frog right true
there's no [ __ ] way you could make
that she came out of sideways you know
so we had this one guy Nate left foot
right foot so yes he had one left foot
had a homie named Danny frog why the
[ __ ] was his name tree frog yeah because
he looked like one he has a tattoo on
his hands right some hood wise you see
oh no not right now but he did you know
yeah he was with a man so but he had a
younger brother so me like I said me and
my friends were all like this I've never
liked bullying [ __ ] I've never liked
that I just it makes me feel so sad
knowing kids get bullied and [ __ ] right
because I grew up super self-conscious
knowing how it feels to kind of be like
oh [ __ ] right but same so all my friends
were like that and this was
one day where I knew like I had the
right group of friends because tree
frogs little brothers start going to our
school when we were seniors at the time
right this I'm giving a shoutout to
moyes what was a little brother's name I
don't I honestly don't some regular name
yeah it was a real name right like Danny
I don't remember but my friend Nick he
told me the story because Nick got
suspended for it right he came out he
was at school the tree frogs brother was
in the ceramic class came out crying
right and he saw these like three groups
of kids like laughing like not kind of
in his general direction but not right
next to him so he goes up the tree frogs
brother because we know him right we all
hang out with each other in north [ __ ]
ask him what's going on said those kids
kept making fun of them low class about
being fat so my friend Nick went up
there my friend Nick's about that action
so white boy but in action just start
shocking every single one of them out
damn socks him out right so then later
on we hear like these kids are talking
[ __ ] like oh we're gonna beat up Nick
whatever like that right so Nick tells
us so we I ditch my last class early to
go outside and I meet with Nick outside
and we're sitting there right and the
kids come out and my front with me homie
Nick so now it's me my homie Nick and
our other friend Thomas sat in there and
we're just sitting there Matt got the
mad doggin these kids and next like hey
you gonna be my ass or what [ __ ] let's
go let's go [ __ ] this kids girlfriends
like he's stupid he's stupid I'm sorry
he doesn't mean what he's saying he's
stupid we punked the [ __ ] out of those
kids I don't know how I'm coming up to
the story but hey bullies have a zero
you have a zero tolerance policy for
boys not really I really do and then
like you ever try bullying somebody
before no and I never I mean maybe maybe
my homies right but it's different like
we're homies I'll bet these trial does
it
exhilarated when I'm like homies I'll
talk [ __ ] to in a punk right but that's
different but no I've never like gone
out of my way to purposely bully someone
I only tried to once in my life and it
didn't feel good yeah and I think it was
because I did grow up self-conscious
about a lot of stuff um so like I never
even felt like I had like I don't even I
didn't know how to bully someone cuz I
was even just scared and simple actually
yeah I was scared to even like I was
scared to talk to girls I was scared to
like do that type of [ __ ] right but as I
start getting older you know do some
people in they would bully people they
were mad creative like I had a friend
not me me me the only time I told the
story in the podcast before but I tried
bullying once and I felt terrible it's
because there's kid who uh who used to
get Punk'd a lot and so they put this
kick me sign on the back of his back of
his t-shirt kicked and so everybody
started kicking him like hard like like
straight-up stomp and him dude like
straight up like stomping him and I was
like and as I remember just kicking him
and I felt terrible and he was crying I
remember afterwards - yeah here's the
thing I didn't tell him that I was one
of the ones kick know cuz I can't live
with that guilt so I came up times like
man I was really messed up with the
fight made his day though but that's
like the example there like I would see
it say I saw that at school I would like
think it's funny immediately been in my
head I like start thinking about [ __ ]
man when this kid goes home he's gonna
be thinking like what is this kid gonna
be thinking when he gets home like [ __ ]
man why is everybody [ __ ] kicking oh
yeah that was how I think and I guess
sad about that
that was the weakness part it was
because I got bullied so much that I got
tired of it that I thought it became a
bully that it would feel good and it
didn't and I remember it so well because
of how terrible I felt and then
afterwards I befriended him and that we
would like share snacks as though he
eventually moved because he got he
continued to get bullied I see that's
what [ __ ] makes him man that boils me
but lightweight then when people try to
bully him if I saw it I would always
defend him afterwards can you lose dude
stomp so get out but let me tell you
something though I
and then we would get beat up together
now it was we were Fred panda I hate it
too when I when you hear it gets to the
point where the [ __ ] kids lead [ __ ]
it was hard I mean I'll be real though I
still remember what he looked like it
was kind of hard not to blow him though
that was me growing up bro Oh bro I got
bullied by everybody people called you
Dumbo for sure I got dude I got bullied
by all like the tough kids you have some
years okay so I used to get chased
around the school I just get bullied by
like all the girls the girls chased me
around honest man no no this came this
is different I understand where you're
going with this but like I said some
kids he still like beat the [ __ ] like he
said beam me up this one a lot of these
two black kids used to be Mia one of
them was named Lorraine and everyone
thought he was a girl of course cuz his
name is Lorraine girl I got bullied by
that kid he liked me sick [ __ ] buddy
he brought a little harder man he broke
my Bruce Lee lunchbox my [ __ ]
greenhorn and I was like I'm in third
grade that was my [ __ ] [ __ ] dude yeah
and then there's other kid named Lamont
who actually was scary his [ __ ] in this
Dookie he said beat me up too because he
knew I did karate as a kid but like I
would never do it at school yell about
right here she already died and he used
to like beat my ass and then all like
there's this kid named well he's
actually really cool now and but his
name was Michael and he's tough [ __ ]
always pick on me he's always like you
know whatever the [ __ ] anything you
think of
I was very soft I was very very
thin-skinned and then I used to get
bullied by a large group of girls who
would chased me around the school and
call me Dumbo until I cried and they
would like how old were you I was
probably like 4/3 for 5th grade 6th
grade seven eighth all the way to like
senior year in high school but like they
just want to [ __ ] you no they don't like
and they would chase me bro I would go
home like balling and then you tell your
parents will beat you up it's like I
didn't get beat up these girls may play
get the [ __ ] out of here do it like
I would cry then in middle school I
would get like people would try to
[ __ ] melon you'll have a bunch of
scissors didn't defend you know they
were like years ahead of me yeah and
they'd be like that's probably yeah I
will feel bad about this year I don't
know why I'm a [ __ ] like we have a
family friend he was at an after-school
program right and I heard this story
my mom my his mom told my mom cuz
they're our moms are real good friends
and I kind of grew up with this kid that
at a at a after school for the summer
program he was standing up and when
everybody sat down someone depantsed him
right he was butt-naked in front of
everybody and everybody saw alright
that's [ __ ] hilarious so like you
know he was young and started crying and
[ __ ] and I remember being at home in my
room thinking about it and I like
started crying about it a little bit I'm
I feel a nice guy man I know but I felt
so bad like I I don't know I think about
how other people feel yeah you're a
better [ __ ] man you got a lot of em I
[ __ ] he's probably feeling like this
right now
[ __ ] I think because you've been there
you know there were certain goals and
girls in elementary school that did
bully other guys specifically there was
this girl named Jules this girl she
sounds like a badass
she was his light-skinned black girl
right her teeth were built like [ __ ]
monster truck time bully because he got
some good ass teeth or a bit like a
monster got so good at making fun of
people though who are really good at
making like his her teeth were [ __ ] up
man like straight up like let's say for
example like she murdered somebody right
and the only thing they had was an apple
that she bit as evidence her teeth were
[ __ ] up dog like [ __ ] she but she used
to [ __ ] people up and I remember the
colors I used to always wear it was pink
and purple were favorite [ __ ] colors
and she always used to have these
knockers in her yeah she was knockers
luck you know whaling on people know she
had new hands and this [ __ ] Jules would
knock people the [ __ ] out all the time
and nobody would [ __ ] with her but
lightweight was because people are
trying to make fun of her face and her
teeth though yeah yes by the way I mean
we had to look at that every day so time
for a bit but but you develop you
develop like those abilities after a
while like yeah at a certain point in
time like for meals around middle school
is when I was like you know what I'm
sick and tired of everyone making fun of
me because I'm Asian
like just picking on me because I
big-ass ears like there was another kid
that he was he was like a good friend of
mine at the time and I went to high
school with him he's actually a pretty
cool dude but at the time like I was
like oh man like he's my buddy and I
went to a new school and I was like ooh
at least I know him and he had big-ass
ears too but obviously mine were bigger
and he would just crack you're like just
the most [ __ ] up like yeah I'm like
damn bro like what the [ __ ] and everyone
else is doing it [ __ ] on me
yeah man until the point where I was
like I'm gonna have to like beat this
gang get some respect yes yeah like
that's Louie what like you literally had
to be like all right bro like I remember
there's one kid he called me like I
think it was at 8th grade and he was
like this skinny little white dude his
name was Ricky and he was like he was
saying something something about how I
was like being a chanc or something like
that and I was like okay and I looked at
him I was like all right tomorrow I'm
gonna fight you in in the locker room
and then like then we punched he was
like no no it's fine it's not like of
course and then I socked them and it was
just like one punch and he was like ah
[ __ ] it he started bleeding and I got
suspended but whatever but it wasn't
that big of a deal but it's like it's
it's you literally have to you know dude
and then nobody will do that you know
what the weird thing is when I when I
first started on YouTube I would tell
these stories about you know like
getting Pilate to get into these fights
and then people I started to realize
like how different other people's lives
are if you don't live in a very like
poor place getting into a fight is not
it's like a rite of passage like every
button if you were a geek nerd whatever
everybody got into a fight yeah it's not
something special yeah so sometimes they
would read these comments in mind you
like I'm a big fat goofy Asian did like
you've never got into a fight I'm not
saying I was good at it I'm saying try
to Punk me all the time dude I'm not
telling you that I'm a thug I'm saying
that when people try to bully you you
have to fight actually in school because
you have like the difference yes you
have like the emo kids the geeks and
[ __ ] one of the one of the people from
another group is gonna talk [ __ ] so the
people you think that are gonna be
fighting all the time they're not
fighting each other it's the [ __ ] emo
kid fighting the [ __ ] yeah the preppy
kid and it's this kid fighting that type
of kid [ __ ] yeah that's crazy it was
just a weird volatile time in high
school cuz like everybody just was just
throwing down man that was like we used
to have like gangs in our school
obviously
but there was a in Sacramento there's a
couple of Hmong gangs right first of all
every somebody Rolla how come every time
you talk about Hmong people it's always
about gang [ __ ] because that's what
y'all do I know but there's a lot of
like I'm talking about if everybody from
Sacramento there's a lot of like Hmong
thugs are we going around not
everybody's like that but that's if
you're from sac town you know I already
know what's that what's up I'm not
saying I mean one of my best friend's
her name is Cathy really close friend
she's mom she and like that but the ones
that I used to kick it with around were
kind of thuggery yeah they were in the
movie Gran Torino
yes they were the [ __ ] yeah and so
these cats were so smart because I
remember one time in high school there
was a fight that broke out and all the
security went there right you know what
the funny [ __ ] was that the dudes that
were fighting I was like though those
guys are homies why are they fighting
they were fake fighting so they could go
ahead and the other homies were jumping
somebody else on the other side the cast
so they were fake fighting so they could
[ __ ] so everybody was we weren't high
school too like we I went to public
school which is passing the high school
and then when people think of Pasadena
if they're not from the area they're
like oh like I was a bunch of like like
rich kids like yeah that's what I
thought when a movie yeah like a low so
but quick fact about Pasadena there's
like nine different private schools in
passing the area because I guess when
the City of Pasadena was resegregate
encase
back together a lot of the white
families were like no my kids will not
go to school
what black kids oh racism they created
like so many different private schools
there's hella privacy in the area and
that's where all the rich kids we go to
and then all the like the like the
regular hood kids or like the mixed bag
at the time when I went to ask was a
pretty mixed bag but was mostly
predominantly black and brown and like
my freshman year it was like there would
be standoffs and like the center quad
fighters would be going around these
fights yeah it was crazy was [ __ ]
nuts and people were like really like
people would get jumped inside the
classroom like crazy [ __ ] like crazy
sure would go down
and like one time we just walked in the
middle of a [ __ ] standoff but that
[ __ ] would happen like No
school had a metal detector there and I
had a police we didn't go that way he
had a police station well that Joe's a
little older than us so when during my
time is when the whole gang [ __ ] and my
school started to kind of taper off and
so my year was things were a lot nicer
it wasn't great but that's how mine was
to like slowly so three years prior to
that three or four years prior to that
it was way worse yeah so like when Joe
was going to high school he had a police
station inside his high school [ __ ]
would go down all the [ __ ] time cuz
Joe used to do some crazy [ __ ] man he
told this one story on the podcast with
this folk that dudes a wild man bro this
why this fool just started like he saw
somebody I guess he heard somebody talk
[ __ ] right long story short yeah he
comes in and then he talked about this
on the earlier podcast you guys go check
that out but this was so psychotic I
guess somebody jumped trying to jump Joe
while he was driving his car and they
started [ __ ] socking him up so he
found out who that [ __ ] was I
found out that he was a barber he went
to get his hair cut at his barber shop
and he was just talking my Vince he goes
he goes I was like so you bought that
life huh and he's cutting him up because
I'm not man it wasn't even me with
somebody as I now as you as the dudes
cutting his [ __ ] hair that guy has
knives he don't give a [ __ ] and he was
just like he's like nah he'll say I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up
as the guys cutting his [ __ ] hair do
a good job I'm a [ __ ] yeah Joe but Joe
saw that dude I guess and they Barton
that was Barton Joe's last fight that
they ever got into is when they [ __ ]
that full up in a bathroom I was never
an aggressor I just always had to defend
myself
it was just like [ __ ] like I got you
never saw yeah I mean yeah I was always
like when even when I was gonna watch
someone fight I was so nervous like I
had flies [ __ ] so like even trying to
get into a fight I was always so scared
so like I liked to Train that's why I
started training in high school right
and I wrestled in middle school and
stuff so I would do that but if it came
to like a street fight that [ __ ] used to
be so terrifying to me because I'm just
like oh [ __ ] like I don't want to
embarrass myself at least if we're
training right I know I'm gonna get hit
and this is gonna [ __ ] so that [ __ ] used
to [ __ ] terrifying I used to be the
opposite when I would like I would try
to seek out fights with people because
in my head I was [ __ ] Bruce Lee like
I would [ __ ] everybody yeah
and up until a certain point in time
like it kind of I was like getting in
fights with like like little [ __ ]
losers you know like they were gonna
[ __ ] do anything yeah I was that
that's how low on the totem pole I was I
was gonna pick down by the [ __ ] no
like the [ __ ] degenerates that no one
really gave a [ __ ] about there but like
in my head and but then the more I
started getting like then I started
training then I was like oh [ __ ] I must
I'm super scared the more I started
training the more I realized that
there's levels to this [ __ ] oh and then
that's when I was like oh I shouldn't
even go like this just be honest like
when we when he and I first started
trying you as funny savant was on you
right and this supposed upon comes that
he's talking on the podcast and he's
like cuz I hey Real Talk when I first
saw you I was like I was like this boy
ain't gonna be here no more than a few
days you know in retrospect he would
come up to me like hey I do David bro
like he's still training me shock but
it's kind of cool with survived because
he low-key he's like lightweight proud
of being props well especially cuz he
owns a gym right and like he's something
from experience right cuz my own uncle
owned one it's like you see like you see
that all the time and usually it's
because it's the people like I know I
know you guys a story right like you
were like I want to do this I want you
had goals I want to do this this this
right and like my world of training
right usually that's the person that
last one month yeah never see again
we're up most people with like big
ambitious goals yeah I want to do this I
want to do this this this this this you
like alright cool we can get that done
for you right
they last a month then you get people
that are like well you know I'll is I
want to do this I want to buy just a
month um so I can learn how to do it and
then so I can start doing it on my own
right and then you end up training them
for [ __ ] years right yeah so like
that's probably why I don't know I can't
speak for him that's probably why you
know you had big goals to do it really
really fat but like it just the the
state of like an MMA gym right or just
like any any gym in general most people
that you see you don't expect them to
stick around you really help because it
does take a special type of person to
kind of have that mindset and push
forward
honestly the easier excuse for for not
doing anything or to not achieving the
goal that you set is like oh yeah you
know I got I have so many things on my
plate right now I can't do this and
that's everyone's default so everyone's
more likely to just kind of stop while
their head like oh I trained a little
bit good I got to I got to have a taste
of it and especially I think that's even
more true with something like like MMA
in general yeah I mean like I said
especially because he owns the gym right
and it's like a fight it's a fight gym
right so like you see people it's not
something where it's like easier in the
sense of oh let me just go lift some
weights right because no matter what if
you are doing a class there will maybe
come point where you're gonna get hit or
something like that something's gonna go
wrong exactly you're gonna be usually in
a 1 for a lot of people when that
happens they leave right so yeah I mean
that's probably why I thought so
oh maybe he's probably and be here now
the amount of people that come up to us
well when I was working there and I'm
still discipline to this day or all the
guys that work at the gym they're like
oh yeah I wanna fight I want to do X Y &
Z dude you already know yeah you guys
you guys he savannas probably heard that
so many times how people always hit us
all by game I need to come track you
know I was looking through a couple of
my dams in today and I was like all
these people that like have hit me up
about training and like yeah I need to
come train with any learn how to do this
never see them yeah yeah never do I mean
it's weird because you know we were just
saying about how when you train more you
become a little more apprehensive to
throw hands because you don't know what
people are capable of yeah that's the
part that's scary right and also too
it's like oh like if you've exchanged
hands with somebody who's better what's
the point it's like what is this like
this is kind of we might as well never
train in life I will never that's why I
like you know you know you have a young
boy that I call him [ __ ] a parasite
boy Oh Daniel yes it looks like you live
in his basement that's his whole life
top ice fried chicken
shoutout meal shout-out to Daniel dam
came to me about last February and I've
witnessed
I've also witnessed David's guess what
do Daniel train with me last February I
would only see a nice to this day I only
see him an hour a week yeah
to this day 1/2 hour on Monday 1/2 hour
on Wednesday he would always show up
unless I was out of town he would always
show up this dude like when he first
came to me in my head I was thinking
like man this fool ain't gonna last that
long
he would smoke all day he was like
talking about how he was and he was very
depressed and he just didn't have really
much going on for him you know he's a
little oddball for sure yeah yeah but
like he's just like us he's just like a
sweet kid you know like he's just a nice
super nice super nice guy and when he
started training he's very timid very
shy and then all of a sudden fast for
it's like a couple weeks ago I see I'm
like I started hiding somebody I bring
him into the group to start training
with us and the first time brought him
in all like dude he was like super
apprehensive like and I was like you're
good dude like just go train go yeah
just move around go spar like we're
doing partner drills everything crazy
we're just like holding paths for each
other and he just couldn't wrap his mind
around that you know but now fast
forward to like a couple weeks later I
bring him back and I'm like all right go
spar like and the only spine we did was
either with Alex the biggest man of all
time and then like me so and he first
started sparring with some of the guys
that are around his his size and then
his like experience level yeah this dude
goes out he's looking like [ __ ]
Daniel no mischenko dude like I could
even believe me David run the side light
we amp like he was pulling [ __ ] out
Ron's like whoo where the [ __ ] you did
one of that for me yeah he's literally
just pulling [ __ ] out of his liking it's
cuz he's so high to give it to him to
because I remember when I first started
training to like sparring in that type
of [ __ ] that that would terrify me
sparring and then to like to see him
right and not saying like I'm the
greatest thing in the world but to see
him how small he is and me and Nick's
like all right you're gonna spar Alex
today and there's a sponsor's okay yeah
I'm like how do you have that because
when I first started training I don't
wanna
this fool she's like okay he's so funny
like it's so funny cause like every time
we do like for exchanging sparring I'm
like I definitely can't spoil him
because I feel like if I hit him he's
gonna crumble hard yeah because he also
throws really hard and that's gonna you
wanna take a shot though cos I mean back
then not that I'm hitting him hard but
there's some times where he like throws
himself into yeah but I see that's what
it mostly is is here because he moves so
crazy sometimes when he throws himself
into I've seen you tag of light and then
his chest hurts after I'm like but that
fool comes right back and does he he's a
gay and boy what it is it's like that
mentality it's like I'm not gonna stop
I'm just keep doing and whatever I tell
him to do he does it and might it might
take me seven times to explain to him
but once he gets it he's got it he's
like a robot not in a sense of like he's
like that but whatever you tell him to
do he he's gonna does it yeah he doesn't
do it yeah he does it and I got to see
him from the began have to see you from
the beginning I remember when you
started training with Nick I was still
over at academy doing Nick's classes so
it's like I remember even I were used to
send my oh damn these they're getting
pretty good man Brian you pretty good
man Brian Perry was like yo dude this
fool but but with the difference like
the common theme with both you and that
guy Daniel is that like you guys would
do your own homework like the Train you
guys would like kind of invest your own
time into it because I only saw some at
one point in time when we first started
training I would only see David like an
hour a week yeah you know it was like
that for the first like four months yeah
exactly and he would just do his all
homework and he would continue to get
like that's where they're good at her
and better keep building his base so
then because people don't do that and
even to this day with like my style of
clients like weight training and stuff
it's like people want to come in and
like they want to workout twice a week
for a half hour yeah and it's like but
then they expect this whole change in
this body they're gonna lose all this
weight and that type of stuff but they
don't want to do any extra work that's
that's hard because right now the
biggest thing that I'm getting I think
is because summers coming up people are
asking me how I lost weight and the
thing is it's like no matter what I tell
you you everybody who has lost weight
watching a video that I did they all did
it on their own and so like there was
something very simple like I said
just walk l don't understand why that's
important and so you know it's if you
don't do take the time to do briefs and
that's anything that you do in life
there's nobody who could just tell you
what to do and then it'll just happen
it's about you kind of taking that
effort and being able to apply things on
your own if you don't do that nobody's
gonna do it for you and that's the hard
part right so if I tell you like yeah I
walked every day and I lost 30 pounds
and but that took a while and it took
this amount of stuff and I tell you I
did the research they go cool all they
hear is I walked everyday that's not
what I said
yeah I said I had to do my own research
and that's that's the part because
nobody's gonna be your parent I have a
friend right now she is a very very
large girl mhm
I've been a very large girl for her
whole life and she saw me lose weight
and this was prior before I lost his
recent amount of weight she for a fact
there are people out there right now
that you're overweight and you keep
telling yourself that you don't care
what you do if you didn't care you
wouldn't keep bringing it the [ __ ] up
Yeah right so first thing you have to do
is be honest with yourself do you like
being fat or are you okay with it yeah
or she goes okay for her she just she
has to do this thing where she goes I'm
still beautiful nobody's talking about
your beauty right now it's a hill it's
your health you are five foot four
you're 300 [ __ ] pounds yeah who's
talking about your looks right now do
you want to feel better every day you
wake up right exactly and she was like
well I have trouble I can't walk a mile
a day you don't have to walk a mile in
hey you just got to do something so for
her there's always a reason why she
doesn't want to do it because she kind
of puts herself in this category of I
can't and she doesn't do the research
she keeps expecting me to give her this
list of stuff at a Hummer losing weight
automatically and it's not gonna win my
thing is to even if you gave her that
they gave anybody that list yeah they're
not gonna do it most of the time you
have to want it for yourself exactly and
this is what I tell people too cuz I get
a lot of people in it's it's about the
most minimal stuff so whatever you don't
do if you can make it a habit even if
it's small even if you go walk for ten
minutes three times a week and you never
do that anyways that's still something
to do so I always tell people cuz I have
people that come in that want to start
training they're like okay so yeah maybe
I'll do four times a week at an hour I'm
like oh yeah I'm like how many how how
much you
trained like what you think oh I don't
do any workout and you know yeah
obviously if I train him four times a
week it's gonna make me more money right
but I know what the effect it's gonna
have on this person we're gonna quit
within a month yeah exactly so yeah and
that's what I always tell people too
it's like start small and basic right
and even if you're like trying to lose
weight in your at home or something like
that this chair I could do a one-hole
workout right here body squats right
yeah I can do it from a sitting position
and from a standing position where I sit
down go up stand up go up if you just do
that two times a week three times a week
what say three sets of fifteen that's
still work that's your body's not used
to so that's usually what I'm trying to
push the pupils like start basic so like
for walking right I use that example for
a lot of people that use weight I'm like
go walk and you don't need to go I don't
need you walking every single day three
miles a day I'm like go walk for ten
minutes yeah yeah three times a week go
walk for ten minutes before you go to
sleep you know if you if you take
showers before you go to sleep perfect
right go walk come home take a shower go
to sleep right add little things into it
because then once you start becoming
that what's it it becomes a habit it's
easier to do I'm gonna make sure I'm
walking a mile every single time I go or
start adding in these extra workouts and
stuff but that's like the biggest thing
you see like in the fitness world is
people people want the results so fast
they don't realize how long it's so they
want the secret yeah so they see David
that he lost a lot of weight right and
they don't know how long it took right
yeah and it's like the same thing like
in the other sense of your other world
like this right you've been doing this
for ten years right yeah ten plus years
people see this so I should be able to
just grow that yeah I have I have this
equipment I should be able to go do this
real fast right and it was like people
don't understand it's it's the steps but
it also is the time and that's the
biggest thing so like if you do listen
to this because David did motivate you
to lose weight and stuff it's all about
the small steps yeah taking the small
steps and I know this from experience
because I've had so many clients doing
it and it's little things and sometimes
I won't even be the weight you're losing
right like I've had a lot of older
clients oh they come to me and like you
know what normally when I walk up the
stairs I have to
you always have to hold on to the
railing I caught myself this weekend
walking on my stairs not touching
anything Oh Mike there you go all right
little things like that is what changes
it and then once those little things
start to happen it keeps you motivated
to go if you keep doing all this a
hardcore extreme [ __ ] you're sore as
[ __ ] you can't even move the next week
you're not gonna keep one and that was
my problem when I first started I used
to go [ __ ] ham yeah magic you just
maxed out every [ __ ] day that's what
I would I mean I would like let's say we
were benching right yeah like it would
be it was always three sets of ten and
everything and then I would load it up
to the max and if I couldn't grind it
out I couldn't grind I would start
grinding out at my second set in the
first five reps but I would try to
complete the third set and the next day
everything is obliterated and like I
couldn't [ __ ] move but that's how I
saw everybody weight trained so I just
assumed that that's how I had to do it
but it was just I started cutting
bashing why she was not weight training
again though thank God yeah you sure hey
dog with us I've been doing push-ups
come on what you see right and with the
weight training it's little things like
people don't focus on form yeah that
type of stuff right all those little
things people just again want to go in
and do this [ __ ] fast right oh [ __ ] I
need to start benching let me just
[ __ ] start doing this you do it slow
it's always the baby steps I always tell
people when I have clients in their new
and they want to start squatting or
benching and deadlifting you know I
usually make them do just a bar for two
weeks if I see you get under the bar to
bench and this [ __ ] is flying everywhere
you're not ready to put weight on sure
if you can't sit down normally with the
bar where you're kind of consistently
straight up and down where you have
control you're not wet ready to put
weight on your body your body's gonna
mess up in a position to where it's
gonna go so like I always tell people
and I've showed him I've lift with Nick
right I've been doing it for a while but
I can bench with the bar I'm gonna hold
in two fingers come down super slow no
shake same with squat
same with deadlift right it's all about
building up the foundation and all that
type of stuff so but people don't want
to hear that [ __ ] I don't want to hear
that they see they see if I use myself
example right they see the numbers I do
okay yeah like okay so what do I have to
do to get there oh my oh you got to do
this [ __ ]
for five years straight yeah like you
know long [ __ ] yeah yeah do it for five
years straight [ __ ]
yeah and it's and if you take anyone
that's successful at anything
the common goal whether they're [ __ ]
David Goggins or Joe Rogan or where the
[ __ ] you wanna like Poland or David well
yeah
the number one thing is consistency yeah
and I didn't you're the best example
because two worlds this and weight loss
yeah yeah everything like you're a
fitness icon now hahahaha
everything has this has they're the
right place right so it's like I know
what I wanted to get out of this and it
was to lose the weight and so because I
lost the weight that's I know what it
takes to get there and I think I had to
fix a lot of these bad habits before
could just to wrap back to that girl who
was like it's like 300 pounds like she
doesn't she doesn't want to take the
actions of trying something beats
sometimes because she's afraid that
she's gonna fail again and she's gonna
feel bad again but the thing is it's
like you also have to realize too
there's personal responsibility in the
reason why you fail you did the same
thing over again and I don't expect why
I understand why you think that you were
gonna be successful doing the same thing
again that's the definition of sandy you
just keep doing things over and over and
over and over he knowing that it's going
to fail you're [ __ ] insane so like
I'm when I started giving her advice
about how to do it first thing she says
she goes walking is too boring okay
you're already in a bad place because
you can't wait train right now you
cannot your joints aren't ready what can
you do
you have no stabilizing muscles
whatsoever you can't do it I know this
from experience I'm saying just walk if
that if you can't do that you won't be
able to wait train five times a week
you'll be able to do Zumba five times a
[ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ] you know it's hard
yeah I personally have done Zumba Dawg I
want to see you do so bad I wanted to be
super super class I personally have done
it and it's very very hard yeah but yeah
like what you're saying is correct and
what I tell people right because I've
heard that too
walking's boring okay so do you listen
to music do you listen to podcasts yes
I'm like do you enjoy it
yes do what do that while you walk yeah
that's exactly what I did I used to
listen to the David Goggins podcast the
one with Joe Rogan
for a month straight every time I walked
because that was like my motivating
I would just listen to there and show
your little fine find something that
motivates you right like even if it's a
song if a part of the song gets you
amped up listen to that before you go
walk but I should amp you up part of the
other thing though too is like I'm
guilty this - like you don't want to do
it because it's hard yeah like people
want a hat like like like when we were
doing the marathon training and I was
training with a BART and I pulled out
because my shits all [ __ ] up
I was I had like when I would listen I
would look at like Bart Strang said I'll
be like what the [ __ ]
like how does this fit all this stuff in
you and the fools on Grindr that's why
that's what it is right it's like this
insane with Dave and all you guys it's
like you guys these guys don't get to
where they're at unless they're make
there have no excuses for their taking
full accountability it's like I didn't
train today I need to get it in at some
point yeah there's no excuses
because if somebody that's as busy as
[ __ ] like the rock like Kevin Hart
could get a workout in every [ __ ] day
like what the [ __ ] do you have in your
play which it's a matter of wanting kind
of understanding where you want to be
and just doing the work like I don't
it sounds so [ __ ] basic but they're
really like you have to erase it like
it's a mental switch that you have to
flip where you are saying you know what
like you have to physically have to be
mentally ready for the changes it's
anything what's your friend like yeah
she has to be mentally ready like okay I
am ready to make the changes and the
thing is is they're gonna hear this
right they hear us talking and then
trust me because I've been in the
situation or I like from being in high
school and super self-conscious and you
hear these people all just do it you're
gonna hear us talking about oh yeah but
it's it's easy it's different it's that
it's about the baby steps and I always
tell him it's about the baby so we
didn't I didn't just start just start
doing this [ __ ] and it was all easy for
me so now I'm over here like oh yeah
just do it yeah I was in the same
position where I was like [ __ ] I can't
it's hard for everybody
yeah it's hard for everybody at the
store all the time you just didn't talk
about it exactly because it's it's it's
it's a mentality thing right yeah like
at a certain point you accept it for
what it is and you just keep moving
forward
like
when I started like weight training more
and I started training with this dude
I'm like bro like in my head I'm like I
think this is for ya like like I would
do I would never want to Train I would
never even when I was doing kickboxing
when I first started training when I
started doing anything I didn't want to
do it it was hard and your instinct is a
right instinct is to like stop doing it
yet cuz it's hard because that's what
the change is
that's where the changes come from
obviously I'm not saying anything new
but at the same time it's like you have
to embrace it yeah and you have them
before yeah anything that works that's
worth having is gonna be painful man
like you just you just have to accept it
yeah you really uncomfortable I just and
stop being [ __ ] [ __ ] fake about
your weight loss too man like if you
want to lose weight because you want to
look good that's okay yeah who don't
want to be better my whole high school
career I wanted to lose weight because I
had zero confidence with girls and in my
head I thought okay if I can get skinny
I should be able to get gross cuz all
these guys that are in shape or skinny
they get them yep so the the reason why
I'm not getting them is because of the
way I look right that's what my thought
was I mean and it's okay that's what
kind of helped me start like alright I
need to start doing something right I
need to start if I really want to get in
shape I gotta go start working out right
and it's always good if you can get
someone that's trying to do it with you
right so if you are overweight not
everybody needs I don't know if you were
walking with people or if you just did
it by yourself there by myself see some
people can do it by themselves and if
you're not able to it's always easier to
do it with somebody
alright and that's me with you Jitsu
that's always on my thing it's like I
don't want to go when I don't know
anybody with the homie yeah I don't want
to go over myself you know I'd rather go
with somebody I know so it's easier for
me I feel more comfortable yeah that's a
thing it's like you want a community it
definitely makes it easier yeah man you
guys you guys can do it do it if I could
do you guys could do a man if I anybody
can do it yeah any way you can do
anything that we've achieved in our
fitness or whatever career you died
could do it so again everybody can do
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast we ended that
[ __ ] on A+ ass [ __ ] no
aah-ha-ha aah-ha-ha you guys can always
do it I promise you I promise you King
is here he will never go ahead the war
is not lost is here yeah why did you say
I think he legit had like a black
panther moment my guy he said he said yo
King is here
he was Hannah a child was dead he was on
call I don't know why I lost all that I
will come back every time I see like
those music yeah he hates I mean alright
a bit well we'll check them out at the
big mad podcast Alexander self please
I'll Xperia J GF on Instagram yo I'm at
Nick the ear I'm Instagram the time
hahaha
we'll see y'all next time yes